we I [ __ ] gained 22 pounds wow in
[ __ ] two and a half weeks like I look
different like we all [ __ ] go [ __ ]
hey what's wrong with these [ __ ] pets
so so the coach goes all right let's see
you guys are [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
whatever let's [ __ ] running
and I can [ __ ] taste that Molly for a
[ __ ] year after that [ __ ] run
you're burping it up you're like oh
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola With Me George Lopez let's do the
show because I got a lot of things to do
a thing I gotta go to that dry cleaner
right here my kid Phelps
new sport sport and Paul
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Robert George Lopez oh my God OMG
oh my God
my best Christmas is I woke up naked
you I mean what what were the
Christmases like when
when you were growing up the
and good Christmas when I would grow up
my mom and dad has one time in the the
year uh I have six sisters no brothers
so everybody to get together at my mom
and dad's house
and as a kid as a kid yeah and Chris
from Steve was always at my mom and
dad's house and they would you guys
would all decorate um they would the
tree was decorated before then uh my job
as a kid was
you know we didn't have mixers or
anything like so my arm was in the Masa
you know going just turning that Masa
trying to get it ready and that's and it
was time yeah there was no [ __ ]
Cuisinart no [ __ ] no this was just
brute [ __ ] strange just get in there
and I remember the test was my mom would
get I said Mom isn't it must have done
yet and she'd get a piece of Masa and
put it in a glass of water and the
[ __ ] thing would sink
and you know get in there and she'd put
more water and then I learned
put the oil in there oil floats
so you put enough oil in that larden
that [ __ ] and come right off oh so I'd
keep going she'd put more stuff in there
and finally you get the float my job was
done then so so it sinks because it's
heavy yeah and it just wasn't whipped up
enough ah and I tell my mom why don't
you buy this Masa preparation no no I
said no you know that's the new way no
she's the old-fashioned way when I got
married
and my wife we made tamales in my house
now for the first time and I told my
wife I said we ain't buying this old
school [ __ ] we're getting muscle that's
already prepared so because you could go
to the a tortilla or Delhi like you know
San Fernando exactly you put the order
in like [ __ ] two months ahead and
then you go out there they would put it
in like a case where the cases are but
they put it in that in that little box
yeah cover it or you walk out with it
exactly all you got to do is get it put
it on the ojas roll it up put them in
and so my mom came down now my mom would
never say anything
bad about my wife never
so my mom come down and I'd say Mom what
do you think about the toilets and he
says I saw it awesome to me well you
really did good these are excellent I
said Masa preparada
and none of that old-fashioned [ __ ] this
is a prepared one she never used the
old-fashioned one again she went [ __ ] it
yeah well because why because it would
take hours probably yeah it was a long
it was a it was a tough job I'm trying
to convince my wife I wanted to make
some more this year
but it's a it's a big thing to make yeah
it's much easier for her to buy it's
much easier to buy it but if you make
you you can't make them by yourself like
I had when I started doing stand up I
had a joke about
they're making tamales and they make
more because I can remember more than
anybody could eat so that was my
grandmother would be like okay it's
gonna be the three of us uh I think we
should make 35 000 okay somebody won
seconds yeah [ __ ] 35 000. and then
they would be [ __ ] you know and put
the thing in there and I said they just
they talked they just kept making them
until they were done talking about
everybody and they would say
who's not here [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
and they start [ __ ] talking about it
and then they would say that wasn't me
or if they talked back my grandmother
would say take the olives out of his
[ __ ] big deal out of all of it to get
all of it yeah so it was that was it and
then as we got older every year matter
of fact I just got done and they're all
they're like to me the models are like
[ __ ] fingerprints there's no two that
are the same no no I don't even [ __ ] you
could you could you could have sisters
standing right next to each other moms
two moms same family
everybody together and they would make
it's just it's there's no it's it's
Precision but it's but there's no
Precision in it like
they know how much Masa they'll say no
no no no no no no bring me those let's
take it off
and then
some people like it with a lot of muscle
some people don't like it with a lot of
Masa and then
you have well you might go to somebody
else's house and they say oh these are
pretty good are they better than your
mom's wife I gotta say that that's not
[ __ ] pretty good right they're always
trying to to like who compare them to
Mom yeah
we we did it and and I'll tell you my
wife learned how to cook because my mom
taught her my mom is the one who taught
her how to cook my best Mexican cook in
town
her tamales are better than my mom's my
mom used to use chunked up pork meat but
it was in chunks that's why my dad liked
it
my wife now makes it all the meat is
shredded yeah so you get meat and every
bite right and they were much but a
little lighter than my mom so I love
yeah yeah so I I used to even my mom
says you know I have a shoes hers are
better she had been it you know back
then but my mom and the only thing my
mom couldn't cook was a steak
you know Mexican for the most part they
make them into jerky you know it's all
Burns right yeah it's got to be well
done over kind of like turkey and uh not
me but also but also if it's like
um
in chunks
it it's like I grew up with the ones in
chunk of that because I got the Harley
they they made them some years and when
she did they were great but not every
all the time but then I grew up with
eating those and those are they're like
balls and then they're tied up in the
ends and not like flat yes okay you know
and the flat ones I think are the more
the way people do them I know they've
been doing them in a kind of in a ball
had some of the house in a ball but also
Ricky from the country club he gave me
he was I got some tamales for you
[ __ ] two [ __ ] badass [ __ ] dude
okay that's probably 10 he [ __ ] eight
eight get the [ __ ] waited for me to show
up and he gave me two of them
and they were really good and they were
flat and they were red and it was hot
and they were good I was like wow these
are good his mom made him my [ __ ]
these are great
there's a guy that makes him I just had
a uh
at an old East L.A reunion guys from
East LA they were back in the 70s uh 60s
70s 80s over at uh Rudy's right next to
Pep Boys Pomona and Atlantic
and Rudy made a I used to take my
homicide team there as a Christmas gift
I would save money up during the year
and take my 14 homicide investigators
down to Rudy's
and he would make lobster Puerto no
Style
and it's the lobster the beans the rice
the salad tortillas salsa guacamole
everything
lunches on me and all your dreams I
picked up the entire tap to say thank
you you guys have made me look good all
year here we go
so we did well we just had one a couple
of weeks ago just like a little reunion
had about 60 guys on there
put it on Rudy makes some good tamales
and my we've been buying them for the
last few years for Michael Madre she
makes some tamales and I told the wife I
said hey Rudy's making some tamales for
Christmas this year again she says I
don't care I like my I like my
Commodities tamales better
I said dear Jesus Christ you can't
remember what Rudy's tasted like four
years ago he hadn't made him since go
with right I said come on you know give
the guy a shot you know at least at
least taste them and say oh these taste
like [ __ ] but don't tell me you like
Commodities better so I just know I like
my Commodities I said all right
so I brought some Rudy's not dumb Rudy
says here take these to the house but
that's a dude making though right yeah
and he's an excellent cook he made send
me a dozen home and I told the wife I
said here taste one
she says oh these are good I said yeah
they're good
I said we've already ordered tamales for
the fireman down the house the other
days but the other was probably going to
come from Rudy's and so we'll see and
what do you eat with the tamale like do
you eat them just like that well I use a
tortillo it's kind of a tortilla
tortilla uh this morning I had uh just
tamales and eggs and chili no tortilla
no nothing just eat that like that it
was good you know I eat them with
[ __ ] bread a lot of people do they do
yeah well we had Julius uh the other day
nice and fresh but I eat it with bread
like what [ __ ] wheat bread one last
night with wheat bread like [ __ ]
forever he makes some uh some good
tamales we'll have some more for the
years uh years up we had rice beans uh
we served rice beans tamales and there
was chili out there there was guacamole
we had pan Dulce forum whatever just try
to feed when we were when we were in
high school we were like seniors
so you take you take the Christmas break
you know you probably would be off like
the for whatever the Friday was maybe
the 14th of December or 16th whatever
and then you didn't have to come back
till
the third or fourth of January right so
we're playing baseball I'm working out
and pretty good
and
we I [ __ ] gained 22 pounds wow in
[ __ ] two and a half weeks like I look
different like we all [ __ ] go [ __ ]
hey what's wrong with these [ __ ] pets
so so the coach goes all right let's see
you guys are [ __ ] eating [ __ ]
whatever let's [ __ ] running
and I can [ __ ] taste that Molly for a
[ __ ] year after that I [ __ ] wrong
you're burping it up you're like oh I
was drinking up I think my grandfather
bought some apple cider from Mexico and
I was sitting there I I'm using my chest
as a [ __ ] board just just eating them
off of my chest
and we were running I
I could not believe how much weight I
gained a short amount of time but also
how much I could taste the bucket that
bottle is what I was running wow
another thing I started doing as an
adult
every year I would write a poem for
Christmas
oh wow everybody get quiet and and I'd
read this poem
how long have you been doing that well
[ __ ] I did it for years I stopped uh
there there was there was a some Trials
of tribulation in my personal household
my daughter was out of the house
so I said no more poems I can't get my
heart into this [ __ ] that was it no more
points
my daughter just turned 51.
my family came up and asked me I was
well I shouldn't say this on a surprise
it'll be too late they won't hear this
as a surprise we want you to do a poem I
should bring back the tradition and how
did you start doing that uh I don't know
how I started doing it I think it's
pretty [ __ ] amazing I mean I would
have loved to have been able to have
somebody say something consistently and
it was it was funny it every one of them
uh people laughed and people cried
so that you know
the
was the night before Christmas and all
through the casa all you could smell was
chili and Masa
you know so I put a Mexican theme to it
named some of the kids in there and what
they did things that happened uh during
the year
this year
uh we talk about I haven't written I
haven't been I've started working on it
but I start talking about uh the fact
that my Mom and Dad aren't here
physically but they're still here with
us anyway they started this Tradition
now we're back so it'll be hopefully
it'll turn out good for it'll be a
surprise to the family yeah that's a
trip man huh because it's like
um
we didn't really do much you know my
grandfather grandmother
but
it's like they're both gone so even
being in the house with them would have
been I don't think I realized that that
was Christmas like my grandfather didn't
take off or sleep all day he was in the
house it was Christmas watching TV and
stuff I mean that's how we did it but
they're gone forever and it like
I'm still here you're in the house by
yourself and you look back on that
little house and then you're like well
maybe it wasn't the most family
familiar Christmas but there we were
like I take one of those again yeah it's
it's always been uh they've kept up we
get we get together every year every and
what is done is it was always at my mom
and dad's house okay then
my dad passed so then we started okay
I've got six sisters so now we move to
my house this year this and we went
around like that now it's been going on
so long so now it's not at my house now
it's at the kids house the kids put it
on
so this year it's my sister's kids that
are putting it on so we'll be at the
niece and nephew's house but every
Christmas day everybody goes there
Everybody Eats they have a gift exchange
yeah and then we leave everybody goes
our way because they all have their own
families and other people that's crazy
so we do and and it really is and you
shop in everything you shop no yeah no I
at this point in time
it's
go to go to the credit union take out
money
and let us let us let them buy what they
want you know give them money instead of
gifts yeah yeah
so it's a trip huh it's a trip man how
things change so it is the only one to
get the my little ones the grandkids
they get gifts the little grandkids uh
they're my daughter's all excited I
bought a I just bought a uh it's uh ice
machine that makes shaved ice like
Hawaiian ice yeah remember Hawaiian ice
tropical ice yeah so I got one and it's
not a cheap one I got one for the house
but it'll it's not for me I don't I
don't give a [ __ ] about that but it's so
the kids will have something when they
come down hey make shaved ice let's yeah
yeah let them have fun so everything's
for the kids at this point in time and
the wife and I just really look back and
they're just happy that everybody else
is happy right
yeah you know and then the day after
Christmas it was really tough it's uh my
anniversary
and so we were supposed to go down to
Steven's Steakhouse
and they're closed they're you know
because of the pandemic they've gone on
to being closed on Mondays and Tuesdays
or our anniversary falls on it oh
they're called even now yeah oh they're
closed Mondays and Tuesday nights and so
uh
we've had to find someplace else to go
so we're going someplace else and we'll
take the kids with us and the grandkids
and a couple of friends
and I think
you know we'll probably have 15 20
people with us and
it's a trip I mean there's a lot of uh
like the holidays get a little bit
depressing for some people you know sure
they do yeah yeah and the suicide go up
yeah and it's just because it's this
time of the it's not during the summer
it's not Fourth of July it's a time
where there's a sharing of love
everybody gets together you're really
missing them because not only are you're
not here to buy them gifts but they were
always here to hug you and buy you gifts
for Christmas it's it's a tough time for
some people
and it it's I understand I understand
life you know because of my job what I
did you know how how special it is
but it's about uh
just sharing you know it's about giving
and sharing and that's all it is it's uh
it's strange because you know uh I was
telling somebody that Ann did Big
Christmases like you know we'd go see
your mom in Fort Lauderdale we take my
aunt mine was little or then if we did
it at the house like it was old like she
went way overboard like loved Christmas
so then I go from having no Christmas or
my grandmother would be like if I'm
gonna buy a tree I want to plan it after
like I've been like a [ __ ] buy a tree
to throw away you're like Grandma
everybody throws a Christmas tree away
well I want to get one that so she
bought one that we replant in the front
yard you know how [ __ ] embarrassing
it is to be in junior high and you got a
[ __ ] Christmas tree in front of your
house all every day of the [ __ ] year
and they were like hey the [ __ ] puto
right there you could find this house it
still has tinsel there's a [ __ ] Tree
in there and it's like you're you're the
kid that has the [ __ ] Christmas tree
in his front yard what kind of [ __ ] is
that
I mean you know because if you didn't
want to buy it and throw it away [ __ ]
yeah
and then you go all right so they go to
The Green Thumb over the Sepulveda and
then buy one you can replant
get [ __ ] we've had a family
and I don't decorate the the the the
I I learned after I retired from being a
cop
for 38 years my world was on the outside
of the house
that was my wife's Castle yeah she does
everything so now I can't get close to
the Christmas decorations on the outside
I can't touch anything you know she does
it all we've had the same tree now we've
had a fake tree
that has been good it's pretty it's big
it's full and
it spins around she's happy with it and
I think I think you know my grandfather
and I I remember a few of them you know
like
we wouldn't plug the lights in in the
house to see which ones needed to be
replaced he'd [ __ ] hang them up then
plug it in and then up there you'd see
which ones needed to be replaced it's
not like my wife I I don't tell her I
don't tell her what to do I we have this
big you know these blow up things 12
foot blow up thing and the winner get it
and then blow it over
and
I try to tell him one time you know what
you forgot that string and just put it
over here on this side hold it this way
no you don't you know that's why I have
them over here all right I won't say
anything and then watch that thing get
blown over every goddamn night so that's
that's her world I don't mess with it
she's happy with it God bless her and
we're you know the and and the Christmas
light would stay up [ __ ] March you
know take them down or else they'd stay
up and it'd be like June you're like
it's almost Christmas yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] leave them up all year round and
then as an adult when I would go see my
grandmother you could still see the
[ __ ] nails still outside of the the
of the boarding around the house where
we used to hang the Christmas tree the
Christmas lights
in [ __ ] 1973 is that [ __ ] see the
nails hanging out
like the one that you you put it in and
then you bend it so that that so yeah
yeah yeah on the safety thing and still
see those in there see now we got Clips
you only got a plastic lifting again
a lot of modern [ __ ] yeah the only thing
my wife does and I just laugh at her
she plugs everything in and it'll be
three in the morning the goddamn stuff's
still lit outside and says I know I
forgot to set the timer
oh I forgot to you know I and so just
about the time Christmas is here she'll
finally get it right and they'll go off
at night crazy
but it's
it is what it is we they enjoy it I
think even in times like this where
uh you know people are so divided by
everything that when this comes around
it kind of resets everybody it does it
does and then and it resets us one of my
sisters uh and she's just the one I've
got two younger ones she's the one just
younger than I am and we do a lot of
stuff together and she says
uh you know I I think I'm gonna break
tradition I don't think I'm going to go
down there this year
you know I know we do it every year but
you know that we live in over here it's
a long drive and I don't know if I want
to really do it same people
and then we went to her uh went to see
the Mavericks in concert Saturday night
and she says okay I'm official I'll be
there I'm not going to break the dish I
realize that's what the family's about a
lot of things can happen yeah yeah a lot
of things can happen so she's she's
going to be with us yeah that's pretty
good man I mean
um
I think
mine and I used to go to
Laker games every Christmas because I
didn't really didn't do much on
Christmas so we would go to
uh the game I'll take her every
Christmas day so I think I'm trying to
get tickets to go I haven't been to a
game and
it's tough with Kobe gone you know yeah
even though he wasn't playing just the
idea of
those are not playing that good right
now no yeah yeah
we're not used to being bad like that
but then you know time will I mean hey
man time moves yeah it moves on I don't
know I've never been a big basketball
fan you know I I just never fun I I've
only gone to one maybe two professional
basketball games the last one I went to
I got to sit on the floor and there was
uh Walton daddy Walton yeah the one yeah
biggest feat and most intense basketball
player I've ever seen yeah I mean he was
just looking amazing he was amazing yeah
just really good man I mean
he was tough it was tough too he went
with Portland
um in the 60s 70s and then he won I
think he won with the Celtics yeah
but he would fracture his feet by going
for a [ __ ] rebound and come down and
break his foot like he's always like bad
um
I I just know it was the most intense
player most dense thing I'd ever seen
how much he concentrated on what he's
doing he was it's a different game
because there's no traditional big man
before like like you would see Kareem
running across or guys that weren't
like Mark Heaton with Utah I remember
seeing him like Lurch you see Lurch
running you know and they just go and
get in position they score and they just
run back to a position like the game's
not that anymore like there's no real
set traditional Center anymore like the
center can run and shoot and pass and
rebound it's like he he has to do
everything now where before the guy
would just sit in there in the middle
and just have the big man and then he
would you know they would shoot
yeah rebound and block block well this
is a good uh it's been it's been a good
year man thank you for oh it's been a
great year I can't thank you the the
company enough this is something I'm
telling you the people ask me what are
you doing [ __ ] this is This Is The Life
of Riley right now and I I don't do
anything just come down here it's like
going to a comedy show every week well
everything everything I do is a pain in
the ass to do except while the show is
not a pain ass dude or this like I I
don't mind
doing it I I [ __ ] less about
like going to NBC with Miami that's I
got nothing but great things about that
and what the future of that brings but
uh coming here too it's been it's been
nice man and and to to be right I just
just yesterday by the way the wife
before I left every time before I leave
she says be sure to say hello to George
she said
Merry Christmas
so my obligation is done Merry Christmas
but I was just telling her yesterday I
said I can't believe it's been over a
year
uh that I've been with you now
and it's uh has it been almost two years
wow
the [ __ ] out of here it should be two
years and uh I just it I'm I'm grateful
it's been fun and most important thing
of anything
is I've made new friends yeah and and
that's that's more important well you
know I was never like like I was never
really
um
the the conversation starter I would say
I mean you can make people laugh in a
conversation but not the conversation
for two hours like we're doing Michael
Rosenbaum I mean we never I never met
him knew a little bit about them but
that was easy it was easy it was having
a [ __ ] great and that's a guy like
that guy has been doing a podcast for a
long time right
successful like he's a success at I mean
well you know but he understands it and
he had a great time he he was just it
was like just shooting the [ __ ] I think
that's yeah that's the beauty of coming
out here is it's just it's just like I
looked them up a little bit I try to
overdo it but even all those guys that
have made us [ __ ] laugh like the guy
that hey araldo Rivera yeah
give me a call back y'all mustache [ __ ]
God bless
uh how hard we're [ __ ] laughing man
God that's a bless I still tell people
that's the funniest man I'd ever that
thing
and I tell everybody I've never seen you
laugh that that much but I mean it was
funny I I used to not laugh well not
here but just in general like I said oh
George's lap you know but I laugh in
here [ __ ] I laugh all the time but I
mean uh that [ __ ] had me [ __ ] done
even when the girls I mean when the
girls come in and they they're talking
about
their sexuality and it's just
fascinating man it's fascinating too
because they're funny
and then you're learning [ __ ] that I
would have no [ __ ] idea yeah or meet
anybody that's pansexual that's [ __ ]
pansexual is Rodney Dangerfield had me
going it was great with this [ __ ]
alert between the two of you going back
and forth but you know Geraldo Rivera
what was it hey uh you ugly [ __ ] [ __ ]
mustache [ __ ] but give me a call back
all right God bless
crazy man funny huh it was [ __ ] Mazda
brownie [ __ ] funny all everybody
that's been on [ __ ] hilarious there's
time to laugh at everything and laughter
is the best thing for any all the wrong
that's going on in the world I think it
I think it I think ultimately man it is
I think ultimately
it uh some people get it some people
don't but I'm going to tell you I if I'm
laughing it's the best part of my best
part of my life that's part of the day
when are you gonna be ready to start
playing to get that on in here I'm
working on it matter of fact if you buy
one or no he gave you one he gave me one
he made it and on the inside it you know
he's got his sticker in there the mosque
uh Tomas Candela and you know made this
yeah and I told the wife just the other
day
like I'm off practice no lessons until
after the first of the year
because it was Christmas holiday coming
up we had this we had that things were
going on you look on YouTube is there
anything on YouTube yeah yeah I'm
following and he sent me he did some
videos yeah that I'm working with and
I'm starting to build a little callus
right here but I told the wife the other
day
uh
it was a good practice I was home alone
you know I said she says did you
practice I said yes I did I gave him a
good hour
and she just had to go I said it was
really good I really I learned something
and that was I was trying to stretch my
fingers around you know to get over to
some of these and then I realized if I
just Arch my wrist
you know right here it yeah it works a
lot better if I if I arch your wrist and
I'm not straining is hard and he kept
asking me
how's your wrist doing and I said I had
wrist is fine just fingers are getting
sore well now I understand why you would
say the wrist because I wasn't arching
my wrist before now I am and
we went to a uh birthday party some
girls uh they went to school with my
daughters and the families there uh
they've been in Mariachi groups they
they used to sing with uh
and there are Mariachi family she's one
of the daughters she's a mariachi still
her husband's a mariachi and the girls
in the the mariachi group were down her
house they weren't playing they're just
there it was a birthday party for her
and one of them was talking to me and
talking to my wife she plays guitar on
for him and when I told her who was uh
giving me lessons uh Richard Mata the
maestro
and he says uh hey Richard Martha was
giving him guitar lessons and she told
them right away says [ __ ] you have to go
all the way over there why don't you I
close her I'll give you that her lessons
right here but we're just she's laughing
but she told the wife and she told me
she was one of these days
all of a sudden the light's going to go
on and it's going to become different
for them and so I told the wife I said
just that little thing just arching my
wrist a little bit started making things
early so it makes me want to go back
makes me hungry yep to get back and do
more well you know I've been playing for
I'm trying to [ __ ] a lot of years now I
don't think I'm as good as I could be or
should be but I enjoy it but I was
putting down in my in my phone songs
that I could start like I don't play the
whole stuff I can get bored and it's a
pretty impressive list of especially I
got all those guitars up there like I
was a guy that
I'm gonna sold flowers to buy my first
guitar in wow in 75.
on Nordhoff and Tampa so flowered by the
Burger King on the corner and uh
uh
and to think of or to see you know a Les
Paul and think [ __ ] man what are those
you know and they're pretty expensive
and then you know now you know I got
some [ __ ] great ones even even Linda
gave me one that was a copy of a 59
redone but there's another one that I
bought from my guy Chris and
I spent a lot of time alone which I
always done but with those guitars
around I feel like it's more rest it's
not alone because you know when we start
back you're working all the time yeah
and there is no time to get away you
won't have these days yeah that you're
able to just relax I I do it at home and
I and I listen to songs and a lot of
these songs that I'm playing right now
but well I'm not playing song I just
listen to the song they're all eating
them
you know it's an A and an e back and
forth
and Ray the song that I want to learn
Easy A and E it's easy
we are going up and down at the bridge
so I've got a lot to learn I just I want
to learn it it's it's coming along it's
pretty cool I'm excited about it all
right man Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas to you brother thank you thank
you everybody for checking us out
exactly we haven't been to him